but it was a choice that you know that I
felt utterly Guided by uh Allah to make
and that is you know I I felt that um uh
my life experience as a Christian
including struggling with Christianity
uh with with aspects of it you know was
a reflection of my search for God and my
search for God wasn't really complete in
Orthodoxy you know while I was Orthodox
through those years uh it's not that I
didn't uh you know look elsewhere saying
you know is this right uh you know I
became Orthodox in a in a church that uh
the parish priesthood died in
1973 i di I became Orthodox in 1978 and
we had no resident priests from 1973 to
1994 we only had priests flying in every
6 seven weeks from the mainland of
Australia so it was a kind of you know a
community without leadership and um and
so that that help shaped my my religious
life I guess